저희가 이번에
스터디 27기를 개강을 합니다 저희
스터디는
2016년도
9월 달에 시작을 해서 수강생이 약
1000명 정도 되고요 그중에
건물주가 되신 분들이
약 200명 정도 됩니다 2시부터
5시까지 3시간을 진행할 예정이고
2주차부터
5주차까지는
강의 시작 전에
답사까지
진행할 예정입니다 그래서 사실 제가
유튜브에서
얘기를 못한 내용들도 되게 많거든요
그런 내용들은
스터디에서 되게 적나라하게 이렇게
말씀드릴 수 있을 것 같고요
빌딩 투자할 때 저는 제일 중요하게
생각하는게 저와 같은 이제 중개사
그리고 은행 지점장 그리고
건축사님이라고 제가 항상 말씀드리는데
그런 팀을 만들어 드릴 겁니다 모닝
지점장님도 중간에 오셔서 소개도
해주실 거고 그리고 건축사님이나 그
다음에 건설사 대표님 또 같이 이제
그 강의를 진행할 예정이거든요 그래서
저희 강의의 취지는 그런 팀을 만들어
드리고 수강생들끼리 네트워크를 만들어
드리기 위해서이 스터디를 처음 시작을
했습니다
정말 준비를 많이 했고 그동안 쌓여
있던 그런 노하우들이라든지 이런게
너무 많기 때문에
앞으로 빌딩 투자의 계획이 있으신
분들은
들으시면 굉장히 큰 도움이 될 거라고
저는 확신을 합니다 그리고 저도
1주차와 5주차를 강의를 하니까 많은
기대를 해주셔도 좋을 것 같습니다
빌딩 투자에 대한 기본 개념 중에
용어 정리나 여러분들이
평소에 좀 헷갈리셨던 부분에 대해서
명확하게 좀 알게 되실 수 있고
아무래도 이제 저같은 경우 이제
실무진에 담당하고 있기 때문에 가장
궁금해하시는 뭐 빌딩시장 동향이나
가장 최근에 거래된 사례 같은 경우도
저희가 직접 설명드리는 경우가
많습니다
빌딩 매입이 고민이시라면 지금 바로
신청하십시오 제작에 잠깐 해드리면
저는 이제 17년
4기부터 13 스터디에서 이제 부동산
관련 법인 설립
강의하고 있고요
벌써 23년인데 한 만 6년 정도
지난 것 같습니다 제 강의에서는
부동산 세금에 대한 이야기는 아니에요
부동산 법인의 설립 그리고 운영
그리고 살짝 세금 그리고 마지막에는
뭐 요새 가장 이슈죠 부실진 기업
재무제표 그래서
단순히 세금 강의가 아니다 그리고
부동산 법인에 정말 설립부터 운영 전
과장에 대한 이야기를 제가 들려드릴
예정입니다 네이버 같은 거 뒤지지
마시고 여기 오셔서 세미나 한번
들으시면 될 것 같습니다
꼬마빌딩의 앱이 건축주가 되기 위한
첫걸음 저희 bsn 건설이
도와드립니다 건물 하나 짓는데 10년
늙는다는 말 들어보셨죠 그만큼
시공하는데
타전 준비 없이는 정말 힘듭니다 저희
bsm 스터디에서 제공하는 강의를
들어보신다면 신축 리모델링을 하는데
이미 절반 이상의 성공을 거두신
것입니다 건축주 분들은 기본적으로
알아두셔야 할 법규 그리고
시공 계약부터
준공까지
시공에 관련된 노하우까지 꼭 필요한
정보를 낱낱이 말씀드리겠습니다 저희
건축 설계가 진행되는 전 과정에 대해
알려드리고 있습니다 건축 설계는
단계별로 진행되는 사항들이 다르기
때문에 그런 부분들을 어떻게 진행해야
되는지 좀 상세하게 말씀드리고 있으며
신축과 리모델링이 또 다른 점들이
있기 때문에
각각의 개발 용도에 따른 그런 설계
과정들을 상세하게 말씀드리고 있습니다
그리고 저희가 설계하고 있는
프로젝트들의 사례를 통해서
실제 건물이 어떻게 지어지는지 그
과정을 직접 보실 수 있도록 저희가
공사하고 있는 현장을 방문해서
답사하는 그런 기회도 같이 제공해
드리고 있습니다 저희 스터디를 통해서
건축주로서의
경험을 미리 해보시는 좋은 기회가 될
것 같습니다